what i want to do is in this video is
talk about a bunch of molecules or
classes of molecules that can be derived
from carboxylic acid and just to show
kind of a specific example i'll show
things that can be derived from acetic
acid and just as a review acetic acid
looks like this
acidic
acid
looks like this since the common name as
i just said is acidic
acid and if you want to use the
systematic name you look for the longest
chain which is right over there there's
two carbons so we use the f
prefix so it's ethn and since this is a
carboxylic acid it is ethanoic
ethanoic
acid now the car the derivatives of
acetic acid and we can later generalize
this to all carboxylic acids we really
just have to change the what's going on
on this
this carbon chain right here won't have
to necessarily just be two carbons it
could just keep going have benzene rings
whatever and that would change the name
but really i just want to give you the
gist and the gist of the naming
so if we were to replace if we were to
replace this hydroxyl group with an
amine and in future videos we'll see how
that is done so if we were to so let me
just draw the acyl group so the acyl
group is just that right over there and
we're just going to keep changing what's
bonded to the acyl group right over here
so if this is bonded to an amine
if this is bonded to an amine so let me
draw well this would be the simplest
amine right over here which would be nh2
this thing right here is called an amide
or an amide
an amide and if we were to give this its
common name this would be acetamide
this particular example would be
acetamide
i should maybe acetamide
and if we wanted the systematic name for
it it would be
ethanomede you have two carbons right
there so it is ethan
ethan
amid now the natural question is nh
all amines won't just have on won't just
be primary you might have other things
other than hydrogens attached to it
other radical groups other carbon chains
so how do you name those and so if you
had a molecule that looked like this
and actually just let me just change
things up a little bit so that we
diverge a little bit from the f from the
ethane root so let's say you had
three carbons
bonded or part of the acyl group right
there and then we are bonded to
a nitrogen which is bonded to
a methyl group
a methyl group and then another hydrogen
in this case you start naming
with this methyl group right here and to
and to show that that methyl group is
attached to the nitrogen you call this
n
n
and methyl and then you look at the
chain that forms the acyl group the
carbon chain we have one two three
carbons so it is prop
protein pro pan
amide
pro pan
amide
if you had another methyl here you would
say
n comma n dimethyl if you had a methyl
here and a propyl group here you would
set you would have called it
n-methyln-propyl
propanamide so hopefully that gives you
a sense of amides now and this is
something we've seen before so it's a
little bit of review
if you have
something that looks like this
if you have something that looks like
this
i'll have it attached to a
methyl group right over here we've seen
this before this is an ester
this is an ester and if we have endo and
let me actually make the part that makes
an ester in blue
to differentiate it we keep substituting
what is attached to the acyl group let
me label it this right here
this right here is called an acyl group
that right there is an acyl group so
right over here for the ester if we were
to give it its
common name and we've seen this ester
before it is acetate
acetate and if we wanted to give it its
systematic name you look at the longest
chain one two carbons so it is ethan
ethan and you don't call it ethanoic
acid anymore you call it ethanoate
the
ether
no eight just like that now the next one
and we haven't seen this one before and
it looks complex but when you really
break it down into its constituents it's
not so bad so let's say we have a
molecule that looks like this
so we have
one acyl group
and then you have
bonded to
an oxygen which is bonded to another
acyl group so it's almost like you have
two carboxylic acids that have been
joined together and you really do have
two acyl groups joined by an oxygen here
this is called an anhydride
and
hydride and they look very complex but
you just have to realize there are two
carboxylic acids attached to each other
and usually the same one
most anhydride you're going to see in
organic chemistry are formed from the
same carboxylic acid so however many
carbons you have on this end you're
normally
going to have on this end so the way to
name these is you name it just the same
way that you would have named the
carboxylic acid but instead of writing
the word acid you write the word
anhydride so this right here would be
acidic anhydride it's derived from
acetic acid
this right here is acetic
acidic anhydride
and
hydride
or the systematic name
is
the systematic name you have one two
carbons so it's ethanoic
ethanoic
anhydride
anhydride and just to make things clear
if this molecule instead of that if we
had something that looked like this
if we had something that looked like
this
where the carbon chains on either end
had three carbons
one two three one two three we would
call this propanoic anhydride
propanoic
propanoic
anhydride
in the unusual circumstance and it is
unusual where you would see different
car different carbon chains here you
would list each of them so if you had if
this had two here and three here it
would be ethanoic propanoic anhydride
but that is very very unusual normally
these carbon chains on either end of the
or both acyl groups will contain the
same number of carbons now the last
carboxylic acid
derivative that i that you should know
about and we've already seen it is are
the acyl halides and in particular the
acyl chlorides so let me draw it right
over here so you have your acyl group
you have your acyl group right there and
then it is bonded to a chlorine
to a chlorine and this right here is an
acyl
acyl chloride
maybe the most intuitive name this right
here is an acyl group and then you have
a chlorine so it's an acyl chloride and
we've seen this exact acyl chloride it's
derived from acetic acid so this is
acetyl chloride
this right here is
acetyl
acetyl chloride
acetyl chloride but if you wanted to
give it its systematic name and we
haven't seen its systematic name before
we have one two carbons so it is ethan
ethanol this tells us that we are
dealing with an acyl group
ethanol chloride
ethanol
ethanol chloride is how we would name
this and if this had three carbons it
would be propanol chloride so hopefully
that gives you at least a good
introduction to the differences in
structures of all these groups and an
introduction to naming them in the next
video we'll talk a little bit about the
relative stabilities and then it'll give
you a good intuition on
which direction a reaction might might
go is it more are you more likely to go
from an amide or an amide to an acyl
chloride or from an acyl chloride to an
amide or anything in between